today's topic the cut truth or drink
oh my god hello you're cute
stop what
jesus you're so cute christ you're cute
no you're cute i want to eat you i want
to eat your food i want to be
you i want to take all your skin and put
it on me and wear it as a gown
i know i like you know you're cute no oh
my god look at your nose i want to throw
them out and just put it on my mouth
just because it's so cute
oh my god that i just uh it just gets
them out
how are you so good at doing that
because we're all wondering
i've seen i've seen it too many times
too many times
when i was uh i work when you work in
service
you see a lot of things not only you see
a lot of things but you
you see a lot of things a lot of
situations that repeat themselves
so girls like that when they meet for
bachelorette or whatever
and it's just for screaming for 45
seconds to a minute and a half and
you're just like oh [ __ ] nice
my ears are bleeding and then after that
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god it's just
that for like the next
five minutes compliment this [ __ ] can
you do that same conversation but just
say omaha
omaha why can't you just do it
it's just chipmunks talking and i like
do your thing do your thing it's okay
but it's just ugh i'm jules i'm nika
oh i'm cameron i am abdul uh i'm joey
i'm jeremy
we met on a dating app why'd you swipe
right picture-wise you were kind of
giving me like daddy vibes or something
maybe i'm just not familiar with how gay
dudes do it but daddy vibes i'm
i'm not that's that's not just kiddies
no there's a lot of girls that like
yeah daddy they throw out daddies like
it was gang signs
they rep they set and they said it's
daddy issues
daddy gang
that's a real game you know what daddy
gang daddy gang is uh the name for that
um
podcast on uh bar stool for the two
girls oh caller daddy
big game daddy gang uh is that the game
that he gained at the game daddy game
and my new clothing i don't even know
what's the knife
the first time i heard all right daddy
yang just two
white girls from beverly hills i was
like daddy
and just like being daddy gang so thank
you so much if i could have a daddy gang
party here
daddy gang i love you so much can we
start
ah okay do i look better or worse than
my photos
i'm the last part says be honest but i
like don't want to say that
you look about the same honestly i'll
take it
do i look better or worse than my photos
be honest oh [ __ ]
uh no you look better really yeah i've
been told that actually in the past
brush it off okay do i look um better or
worse than my pictures than my daddy
pictures
i think you look the same
that is a lie yeah if you're pausing
that long you're just trying to soften
the blue yeah i think
there was something there was a pause
there no no no it's like it was a good
representation i think
okay why did he turn on his hr mode all
of a sudden
no no it was um
sam is it yeah all right um um
hmm it was fair it was honest
everything to bitter repeat around the
bush
how tall did you say you were on your
profile let's verify with the measuring
tape oh
easy six too after six foot you don't
need to lie anymore
everybody below six years like oh that's
pretty true
that's true that's true i feel like
everyone's just trying to hit that sixth
number and then after that they feel
safe so i feel like you should just
measure your height in centimeters from
now on just don't ever say feet
if you're under six feet if you're on if
you're over six foot and you're part of
my master race
all right if you can just [ __ ] stand
by everyone but hey hey
look just just be fair uh how tall are
you
six feet six ladies that's a message to
this is the difference between 5 10 and
6.
the world
it's okay bro you off the market it
don't even matter i know i'm just
playing they don't even matter
honestly though i appreciate um
being six foot because personally i i
value value
didn't you say you're like five foot no
i said i'm less than five feet tall but
people look up to me
and what are the odds that you come on a
date with someone and both y'all wearing
like a dress shirt with flower patterns
ain't shaving square hair anyways what
are the odds
i'm pretty up pretty pretty good that
both of them show up with
i mean they're lesbians
through the wall like the kool-aid man
and you said
what are you looking for on tinder i'm
definitely like a romantic
type i like to spoil a [ __ ] huh huh
wait
what who i'm the romantic type
i like the spoiler
what happened no no bring it back bro
bring it back
i'm definitely like a romantic type i
like to spoil a [ __ ]
oh okay so basically she likes to give a
lot to the person that she's with
spoilers
that's how these kids talk damn i'm
saying kids now
guess who old now let me find one that's
wait wait he's supposed to be reading
him right
yeah i'm supposed to oh you can just go
through oh my god go ahead
what do you know someone i know all
these are you serious what
i know all these people that's super sus
why is this
a guy told me on twitter on he told me
on tinder he's like yo
a guy told you on tinder no a guy told
me about tinder the guy
told me on twitter he told me on
tinder he's like yo like yo he told me
on tinder i match with girls and
you because you can see after that with
the profile who they have in link with
friends and i'm friends with all
like a lot of them girls i'm like yeah
oh
some of them have their facebook link to
their account but a lot of them most of
them don't don't
early on you had that a lot people were
linking but not but that was yeah that
that comment
but yeah that comment was from four
years ago so
yeah that sounds about right after a
while people realize they shouldn't do
that because then people would find them
on facebook directly and stock them
stop the [ __ ] out of them right so yeah
you should see that but
i don't know but i would never
it would feel weird if i lived in a
major city and then you would match with
all the people i know
or a lot of dudes that i know i mean if
you know
know a lot of people i guess but for me
is never really a great sign
because i don't like the idea i go on
online dating to meet people who are
outside of my circle
not to meet people who i would have met
through friends of friends that's not
the way i like
well that's just me have you ever had an
sti scare what happened
ah yes i did um
it was like i think like a gonorrhea
scare type of thing
um and i think i like went and got like
treated for it even though it like was
not positive but that's what they do
anyway so
i feel like these guys had like
kimberley a couple times and she's
looking like just gone over here once
have you ever had an sds card so my ex
tested positive for chlamydia
oh so did i
guess exactly which one he had to
your wizard we already know that
for those of you that don't know that by
now he's a wizard i'm actually a little
bit kind of grossed out that i guess
this one
but he said i should go and then i went
and got tested and i was negative so
okay
okay okay
what are the chances this date ends in a
one-night stand
you know if you're not down zero
if you are down
a hundred is that how it works
is that how probability works
this guy is what i like this guy i like
this guy if you're not down zero if
you're down
100 that's the smartest
dude that has got to be the smartest
answer to that question i think that's
most men in women's
[ __ ] dating experiences men to show
up on dates like
whatever and girls are like
guys sounds like a zero to me
it was interesting uh it was all right
five out of ten
so is it you can't say that it was all
right five out of ten
that's a five out of ten what was that
what's all right for you
all right to me it's a seven a seven all
right it's a seven
hold up if ten is perfect what is nine
pretty good nine which is almost perfect
it's pretty good yeah
what is an eight good seven's all right
all right what's six average
five below average but i thought you
said
i always said all right and you're like
i don't understand
but it's all right it's average two yeah
yeah that's why i said it's a five out
of ten so
i said six five is is like
it's not even the passing grade you get
five out of ten you don't pass your
classes
so five to me like the average the past
is 60 to me that's average
five is blood low average taking it from
academic background
i'm sticking out of a rating if i'm
writing so that's a rating no but if i'm
writing something out of ten okay that
ten if ten is perfection yeah literally
we're saying ten is perfection
perfection nine is pretty much
superb you're really just right there
you're a few inches away
eight is very good okay
it can't be just good because if nine is
superb almost perfect then it can't just
be good
at eight i can that's why we have eight
point five eight point five
and nine point five and decimals
i mean listen you know what your rating
scale subjective so you live your best
life okay
you want to run your daddy gang that way
do you think daddy daddy
daddy daddy tell us how your rating
system works we want to hear it and if
you want to be part of the daddy gang
leave a comment below
[Music]
foreign